[Music]
start with a crisp high fiber crust made
of freshly milled and ground flour add
tomato sauce made from whole tomatoes
talk with hand-torn mozzarella and
paper-thin air-cured prosciutto and bake
for two minutes at a thousand degrees
voila
this is Chipotle's take on pizza I would
say we're doing very well I mean pizza
Rilo Kiley's is growing faster than
Chipotle did in the early days in 2011
Chipotle founder Steve ELLs quietly
partnered with James Beard award-winning
chef Lachlan Patterson a master
sommelier
Bobby Stuckey to launch a fast casual
pizza restaurant in Denver Colorado the
goal to bring Naples to a city near you
with Chipotle's backing Patterson and
Stuckey will open their second fast
casual location this weekend further
expansion plans are in the works they
want to keep the food as accessible as
the burritos tacos and guacamole made
famous by their deep-pocketed partner
like Chipotle pizzeria locale ease food
costs are higher than those at most fast
food restaurants nevertheless prices are
competitive a margarita pizza will cost
you $5 75 cents a veggie pizza $7 75
cents and a salad $3.50 two five and a
half dollars a glass of Stuckey's own
house red five dollars like Chipotle
there are no freezers food is made fresh
every day like Steve ELLs Patterson and
Stuckey are sticklers for details you
can read a newspaper through every
pizzeria locale a includes a prosciutto
slicer from northern Italy and a unique
of it it's an oven that we created to
simulate the perfect spot in a
traditional Neapolitan we've actually
designed it we actually designed this
wheat is milled and ground on-site this
is a mill that was hand-built in Austria
and we're going to turn wheat the canvas
of every pizza back to how it was 150
years ago even the environment for
uncooked dough is a priority well this
is a temperature controlled dough room
to simulate the temperature and humidity
of Naples scaling these details to a
second location and to new markets is
the challenge ELLs will set a target for
the rate of expansion for pizzeria
locale a nor disclose the terms of the
financial deal but he's excited by early
results I've heard a lot of people some
of our investors and others say that
they think Pizza could be bigger than
Chipotle itself so if that happens
that's great